what we're going to do in this video is
diagram out how a bill can become a law
and i make a distinction between a
non-tax bill and a tax bill because a
non-tax bill can be introduced into
either chamber of congress initially it
could be introduced into the senate or
it can be introduced into the house of
representatives while something that
deals with taxation can only be
introduced initially into the house of
representatives and as we've talked
about in other videos anyone can be
involved in the drafting of a bill but
it actually needs to be introduced into
the appropriate chamber by a member of
that chamber
but let's say that it gets introduced
into the senate what happens then
well it will be referred to the
appropriate committee and what is the
appropriate committee well if it deals
with foreign relations it would go to
the foreign relations committee if it
deals with the armed services well it
would go to the armed services committee
you get the general idea
now in the committee they might have
hearings they might debate it and if
they decide to debate it and have a vote
on it it could pass so let's say it
passes through the committee
and then the majority leader and the
majority leader is the leader of the
majority party in the senate they have a
lot of influence on how and when that
bill gets debated on the senate floor
but let's say that they schedule it for
debate on the senate floor once things
get to a vote on the senate floor they
need a simple majority to pass
so let's say that this bill passes and i
know what you're thinking you might have
heard numbers like 60 out of 100 votes
or two-thirds majority where the
two-thirds is necessary to ratify a
treaty
the 60 votes that's necessary for
cloture to end most filibusters and so
functionally it often does require more
than a simple majority support in order
to get even to a vote but let's say that
this bill that was initially introduced
into the senate makes it all the way
through
what happens then
well if there isn't a similar bill that
was introduced into the house of
representatives and got through the
house of representatives this bill would
then go through a similar process in the
house so then this bill would go
all the way would be introduced into the
house of representatives it would be
referred to the appropriate committee
and then once it passes through the
appropriate committee it would go
through the rules committee and the
rules committee is one of these major
distinctions between the house and the
senate the senate does have a rules
committee but it is nowhere near as
powerful in the house the rules
committee can control a lot it can
decide when and how or even whether a
bill even gets to the floor
but let's say it does get to the floor
and then it gets a simple majority of
the house members to vote for it well
then this bill would then go to the
president
now some interesting things happen once
it gets to the president the president
can of course decide to sign the bill
so then sign the bill in which case that
bill will become law
the president could also decide to veto
the bill now if the president vetoes the
bill it would go back to the chamber in
which it originated in this first
example that we were talking about that
vetoed bill would go back to the senate
and in order to override the veto they
would need a two-thirds majority and
even if they were able to get the
two-thirds right over here it still
wouldn't become a law then it would have
to get the two-thirds in the house but
if it was able to get the two-thirds
there as well well then they have
overridden the president's veto and it
will become a law
now there's other edge cases that
involve the president if a president
does nothing for 10 days and if congress
is in session for those 10 days well
then it can become a law
so nothing
for
days
well then you can also make it a law and
there's also something called a pocket
veto where the president does nothing
but the congress goes out of session
within that 10 days and so let me do
this this would be a pocket
pocket
veto right over here and i'll just put
that in quotes because that's also the
president doing nothing but congress
goes out of session within those 10 days
now one thing to be clear even what i've
drawn here is a simplification there are
many steps in this process where bill
could change where a bill could die or a
bill could just go into some sort of a
limbo state for example a committee can
decide to add to a bill that would be
called amending a bill so that could
happen over there it can actually happen
other places maybe a bill does not pass
through committee
not
pass
maybe it does not pass through the floor
action
maybe it doesn't go maybe it doesn't
pass the house committee maybe it
doesn't pass through the house all of
these places are where a bill
could die
there's also situations where a
committee could decide to table a bill
which is not saying that we have voted
against it but they're saying hey we're
not even going to vote on it and it just
goes into a little bit of limbo but
essentially the bill will die there so
it could get tabled in committee in
either
chamber even the rules committee could
decide to table it so it never really
makes its way to a vote on the floor now
it's also important to note that in the
example we gave a bill started in the
senate made its way through the senate
and then had to make its way through the
house and eventually got to the
president's desk it could have gone the
other way it could have started in the
house of representatives in fact if it's
a tax bill it would have had to start in
the house of representatives and if it
got all the way through the house then
it would have gone to the senate it
would have to go all the way through the
senate and then it would end up on the
president's desk and oftentimes you have
a situation where two parallel bills are
making their way through each chamber so
there could be a bill that's making its
way through the senate say on
immigration and there could be a
parallel bill on immigration making its
way through the house of representatives
now if each of those bills get through
their respective chambers then they go
to something called a
conference
committee which is a place where both
representatives and senators of the
appropriate committees will get together
and make their bills gel together now
even if they're able to agree to a
unified bill so to speak one that sinks
the two bills that went through both
chambers then that synced bill would
once again have to go through both
chambers again so it's not like the
conference committee can just decide
and even what i've drawn here is a
simplification there's all of this
whether you consider it interesting or
not parliamentary procedure and nuances
that allow different players especially
the leadership in each of the houses to
have a lot of levers to either
accelerate the passage of a bill or to
kill it in different ways